I had so many dreams of where I wanted
to go,
who I want it to be,
and what I wanted to do.
Theater companies.
I wanted to start with classmates,
movies.
I wanted to be in directors.
I wanted to work with stories.
I read it to tell,
it might take a little time I thought,
but it would happen
when I sat there,
excuse me,
22 years ago.
Okay.
What I didn't want to think about is
where I would be tomorrow,
what I would have to start to do
tomorrow.
And I graduated in 1991 a great year,
uh,
time of resurgence for independent films
in this country at a time of relatively
affordable rents in New York City.
See,
I assumed that I could make a living
writing my place,
acting way off,
off,
off Broadway and hopefully one day join
the actors I loved and respected in
those independent films.
TV.
Oh,
what?
No.
What?
Are you kidding me?
Okay.
No,
didn't even consider that I have much
more class than that.
Much more self respect than that.
Soap operas and ship.
What I didn't have was cash
a bank account,
credit card or an apartment.
I just had debt.
Okay.
Big,
hungry,
growing larger every moment.
Debt,
so as you will tomorrow.
I had to leave beautiful Vermont.
I pack the life that I knew with socks
and a toothbrush into my backpack and I
slept on couch after couch after couch
after couch at friend's apartments in
New York until I wore out their rent.
Pang roommates welcome.
I didn't want a day job.
I was an actor.
I was a writer.
I was at Bennington graduate.
I had to get a day job.
I dusted pianos at a piano store on
ludlow street for five months.
I worked on the property of a
shakespeare scholar for a year,
pulling weeds and removing bees nests.
I went on unemployment ones,
but for not for long.
I couldn't handle the guilt.
Eventually I was able to pay rent for a
spot on the floor of an apartment on the
lower east side,
but my roommate had a breakdown and
disappeared.
He later resurfaced in a religious cult.
I'm making this sound romantic.
It really wasn't it.
Yeah.
I helped hang paintings at galleries,
paintings.
That inspired inspire you to think I
could do that.
Yeah,
and then finally,
after two years of job and couch
surfing,
I got a job
in application processing as it data end
juror at a place called professional
examination services
and I stayed for six years,
six years
longer than my time at Benning
from the age of 23 to 29
board.
They loved me there.
I was funny.
I wear black,
no cape,
no tights.
Yeah,
I smoked in the loading docks with the
guys from the mail room and we shared
how hung over.
We all were.
Okay.
Everyone.
You called each other's shorty?
I don't know.
Seven shorty.
Hey,
you doing shoddy or so hung over?
Shorter.
Yeah.
I called in sick almost every Friday
because I was out late the night before.
I hated that job and I clung to that job
because of that job.
I could afford my own place.
So I lived in Williamsburg.
Brooklyn.
Yeah.
You say that now
my kingdom for a time machine.
No.
Yeah,
that's right.
I lived in an industrial loft.
My rent was $400 a month.
My dream of running a theater company
with my friend,
fellow Bennington graduate,
Ian Bell had died.
I won't go into those details,
but neither one of us had any business
sense.
And the theater we lived in,
it had no heat or hot water.
We didn't smell very good,
but we had our youth.
The youth gets old very quickly.
You'll see.
So Ian moved out to Seattle and I moved
up to the street to my loft and I still
didn't have heat
in 1993 industrial loft men not legal to
live there.
I didn't see,
I don't want this to sound cool and I
feel like it's sending cool
ad Lib.
Uh,
but I did have hot water,
hot water in my bathroom,
which a friend of mine using said
bathroom once shouted.
It smells exactly like a summer camp in
here.
Okay.
It was true for some reason in the
middle of Brooklyn,
there was earth in my shower.
Sure Earth and then,
oh look,
mushrooms growing from the earth.
But I,
I was safe though.
The ideal fire control company was right
across the street where they make all
the chemicals that put out chemical
fires.
I did not fear a chemical fire.
I would be okay.
And all those chemicals in the air.
We're okay too because up the street we
had the spice factory.
They made spices and that just covered
everything up in a nice cumins centers.
I had a rat,
but that was okay cause I got a cat.
Yeah,
his name was Brian.
No relation.
My grandmother had given me a pink
pullout couch.
Oddly new friends or recent graduates
wanted to crash on my couch.
So I put the couch on its end so brian
could climb it and look out the window.
I had only the one window.
I myself could not look out the window.
It was,
it was quite high.
So I had no heat.
No girlfriend.
What are you kidding me?
No acting agent.
But I had a cat named Brian who told me
of the world outside.
I stayed for 10 years.
Yes.
No,
don't pity me.
There's a
happy ending.
When I was 29 I told myself the next
acting job I get,
no matter what it pays,
I will from now on for better or worse
be a working actor.
So I quit my position at the
professional examination services.
My friends really weren't happy about
that because he was so easy to find me
when I work there work was,
there was the only place I had the
internet.
This was at the beginning of the
Internet and now I didn't have either
the internet or a cell phone or a job,
but something good happened.
I got a low ping theater job in a play
called imperfect love,
which led to a film called 13 moons with
the same writer,
which led to other roles which led to
other roles and I've worked as an actor
ever since.
Bye.
Didn't know that would happen
at 29 walking away from data processing,
I was terrified.
10 years in a place without heat,
six years at a job I felt stuck in.
Maybe I was afraid of change.
Are you?
My parents didn't have much money,
but they struggled to send me to the
best schools.
And one of the most important things
they did for me and graduates,
maybe you don't want to hear this,
is that once I graduated I was on my
own.
Financially it was my turn.
Herons are applauding graduates or not.
This made me very hungry.
Literally
I couldn't be lazy.
Now I'm totally lazy,
but back then I couldn't be.
And so at 29 and a very long last,
I was in the company of the actors and
writers and directors.
I had sought out that first year,
that first day after school
I was,
I am by their sides,
raise the rest of your life to meet you.
Don't search for defining moments
because they will never come.
Well the birth of your children,
okay,
of course,
that's just six months.
She's,
my life is forever changed and that's
much defining moment ever.
But I'm talking about in the rest of
your life.
And most importantly in your work,
the moments that define you have already
happened and they will already happen
again
and it passes so quickly.
So please bring each other along with
you.
Everyone you need is in this room.
These are the shiny more important
people.
[inaudible]
sorry.
It sucks after graduation.
It really does.
Okay.
I mean,
I don't know.
At least it did for me,
but that's the only thing I know
you do.
You just get a bit derailed,
but soon something starts to happen.
Trust me.
Rhythm sets in
just like it did after your first few
days here.
Okay.
Just try not to wait until like me,
your 29 before you find it
and if you are,
that's fine too.
Some of us never find it,
but you will.
I promise you,
you are already here.
That's such an enormous step.
All its own.
You'll find your rhythm or continue the
one you,
I've already found.
I was walking downtown in Manhattan the
other day and I was approached by a
group of very sweet young ladies,
easy
actually there.
Erm,
sort of running fever actually down the
street after me.
When they got to meet breathless.
It was really,
they didn't know what to say or couldn't
form the words,
but it came out that they were Nyu
freshmen and they were majoring in
musical theater.
Of course.
Come on in.
We're like science majors.
We were running after me.
What musicals are you doing?
I inquired.
Well,
one of them said,
looking down at her shoes,
we aren't allowed to be in plays our
yet.
Our freshman year
now.
They were paying very high tuition.
Yeah,
tuning,
not do what they love doing.
I think I said,
well,
hang in there.
Yeah.
What I should have said was
don't wait until they tell you you are
ready.
Get in there.
Sing.
We're quickly transferred to Benington.
[inaudible]
when I went to school here,
if a freshman wanted to write direct and
star in her own musical,
the lights would already be hung for
her.
Yeah.
Now I tell this story
because
the world might say you are not allowed
to yet.
Okay.
I waited a long time out in the world
before I gave myself permission to fail.
Please
don't even bother asking.
Don't bother telling the world you are
ready.
Show it.
Do it.
What did Beckett say?
Ever tried.
Ever failed.
No matter.
Try again.
Fail again.
Fail better.
Okay.
Bennington,
class of 2012 the world is yours.
Treat everyone kindly
and light up the night.
Thank you so much for having me here.
[inaudible].